there's really no territory we probably
couldn't get into that you don't have
knowledge and statistics and uh you know
some recommendation on it's it's really
amazing thank you that means a lot that
definitely means a lot and listen so i
just i've been diving into your world as
well and i just listened to your episode
with greg braden oh my god
okay
that's like
for sure
greg is like my everyday thoughts like
those the things that we talk about are
i love the universe i love quantum
physics i love reality
and um
i've always been into health and
wellness but when it comes to
when it comes to
all of that kind of stuff i'm like oh my
god do you think about that stuff too
of course you know when all of this
craziness start to kick off the first
two people that i look to like what is
their perspective was bruce lipton
and greg braden oh my god so yeah i know
bruce so fortunately like i was able to
have a conversation with him and feature
his perspective
and i mean my goodness it was just it
was very affirmative because i kind of
already knew where they would take
things and i mean they were both just
kind of um
really
trying to shift our focus back to
you know empowerment and being able to
take a meta perspective on all of these
things and bruce was really hammering
home he took the took us through really
the biology of fear and how that's
compromising our immune system and this
was over a year ago when i had him on
and talked about it
and i don't know if you saw this but i
posted the cdc study the most recent
study and so they analyzed it was 800
u.s hospitals over 540 000
uh covert patients and they found that
the number one risk factor for death
from covate was obesity which is
something we know are we doing something
about it of course not
but the second leading risk factor for
death from covid in this massive
meta-analysis
was anxiety and fear-related disorders
well then my questions that i have in
mind are going to be perfect i mean
bruce i've learned so much i mean i want
i would i would love an intro to bruce
we've been i've been trying to get him
on i've had greg and then the other part
of this like little trio is joe dispenza
like those guys end up going out and
doing speaking and speaking gigs and
stuff and so i've had joe on i've had
gregon and i really want to have bruce
because the epigenetics epigenetics
fascinates me and i have so many
questions about epigenetics and how you
know i was listening to him talk about
splitting um having a i think it was a
what would it have been a gen a gene
that was multiplied into like 10 000 10
000 of them were multiplied into and
then they split them into three dishes
and each of those dishes were given
different environments and then all of
those genetics became the environment
and so
like this whole idea of epigenetics and
how we become who we are and if we
if epigenetics is something that we have
to be cognitively aware of for it to
become our become us or if we're able to
just be in proximity to it i mean i'm
just so so so fascinated by all that
he's a pro at that first of all i'll
connect you so that's already done
second of all the thing that he always
brings me back to
even when i talk about the environment
even when i talk about
you know various expressions and
potential he
always leads me back to the fact that
your thoughts are the most powerful
influence over all of it
it is your thoughts that are determining
your genetic expression you know to the
nth degree so whether we believe in it
or not it's still creating yeah and yeah
so it's super fascinating yeah well
we're creating our reality i mean when
you
you know people have said for a long
time that
you know this is just kind of a stage
and we're actors and we you know we're
just
whether we're holographic in nature or
not but our thoughts are creating our
reality and i think wasn't it the double
slit experiment that showed that that
when you put attention on
to something it changes it which means
that our our our conscious awareness to
something is what's creating that's just
mind-blowing
it is but this is you know it's
put it under this big umbrella of the
observer effect
and you know there's even a really
fascinating study i first learned about
it from greg braden and it was the the
phantom dna experiment
and
and so the thing about me too is like
i'll take those things and i will just
like
go in deep and actually you know review
the analysis review the studies the
outcomes and start to look at start to
question things like what did they not
see in this what could be another
potential what's another explanation
but the phantom dna experiment um
basically they took a vacuum which if
you have a vacuum and i'm not talking
about a vacuum cleaner i'm talking about
like a chamber that eliminates
everything from being able to enter it
or to leave it
and there's no like you know oxygen
infusion of that stuff is just a it's a
it's a closed vacuum seal
and there would be nothing in the vacuum
they made sure that there was nothing at
all in the vacuum but there's something
you cannot possibly remove which is
biophotons these kind of
little
packets of of of energy of light that
make up our reality
so there's nothing they can do about
that and so what they did was they took
some human dna and put it into
the vacuum
and something really strange happened
the biophotons that were just kind of in
the seemingly random assortment
throughout in the vacuum
conform themselves and basically attach
themselves to the human dna
they left in their scattered arrangement
and conformed to the dna
now that was already interesting and now
here's where it gets really weird
they took the dna out and expected the
biophotons to just go back to their
scattered seemingly random arrangement
but they didn't they still stayed in
conform and confirmation
with the human dna as if the dna was
still there
so for that moment the human dna
left a permanent impression upon the
very stuff that makes up our reality
and so this speaks to again that's just
a tiny portion of our dna let alone this
conscious sentient being and how much
power we have on influencing the world
around us
so you know it's experiments like that
but then it just goes back also to
you know when i mention our thoughts
influencing our our genetic expression
every thought we have
creates correlating chemistry in our
bodies instantaneously
and this is the rub is that whether the
thought is real based on accurate data
or if it's based on something that's
totally made up
your brain and your physiology don't
know the difference but you are
instantaneously changing
your entire biochemistry every single
cell in your body the trillions of cells
are instantaneously changing based on
your thoughts every single microsecond
i've been saying thoughts become things
for a long time i watched a secret back
in 2008 which is still a couple just two
years after it came out so it's still
pretty early and i watched it before i
interviewed her recently and
in it i don't remember exactly which one
said it but it's like thoughts become
things and i was like oh my god that's
why i've been saying that for so long
because that's probably where i heard it
and you know you're just explaining how
that's true and so what i love is that
because you're such a you're such a deep
diver on the information and the and the
analytics of things and the science and
and the technical part of part aspect of
all of these things or thoughts that we
have or awarenesses that we have which
is so cool because there's so many
people that are willing to take things
at face value and then you know
that's fine um but it's when you can
truly explain it from a scientific
perspective from a biochemistry
perspective
that it really convinces and anchors
people into
a new level of
not just awareness but belief in that
awareness because belief is like the
magic sauce to everything it's one thing
to say you know i can go drunk a
basketball it's another thing for me to
actually go believe that i could go dunk
a basketball so um because i'm five foot
one
um so that that believing is i think
what really will help people transform
which is why i'm excited about this
conversation because you know i feel
like in our world today there's so many
so much going on there's so much like
outside of our control
um to directly go out and do something
about and so the only control we really
have is over ourselves
and you know in
the truth is is that the collective
holds the power and so so long as we
participate in a system participate in a
thought pattern or a paradigm it
continues to exist like i say you know
if you don't think that the newspapers
telling the truth stop buying it and
they won't exist very long you know if
you don't think that the news is telling
you the right thing on the television
stop watching it and i promise you it'll
go away and so what i want to have a
conversation about is not necessarily
out there but in here and what can we do
because
basically if we all changed our our and
i'm going to hit some buckets with you
because you just i just i'm fascinated i
love the knowledge you have but if we
can affect our mind and our body and our
spirit and all the things that have to
do with us if we all did that the world
would be transformed